ok go go pour la mission tweak on voit
toutes les semaines nous à l'épicerie
pour aller faire des recherches tels que
l'alimentation pour moi ça fait partie
de mon projet éducatif
[Musique]
christine des propriétaires d'une
garderie en milieu familial à autre
saint-pierre ville de 3500 habitants sur
la côte nord les frères ton temps les
frais
l'épicerie ici on a juste une puis on
n'a pas le choix de bannières de ce
qu'il faut pour remplir un garde manger
comme partout le sait sauf que qualité
il prit ses différentes pour faire quoi
quant à eux terminé nos achats
parfois elle est tentée d'aller faire
ses courses dans une autre ville est
loin même si je sais qu'il ya des ajouts
intéressants que je peux faire
comparativement à issy les ouvre le maxi
et à sept-îles c'est quoi c'était par
rapport à ici les 222 km fait que dans
le fond sur michal c'est une vivre dans
une région à faible densité de
population nécessite une bonne dose
d'imagination et de planification avant
de passer à table
ce que j'ai compris c'est que tu peux
pas te lever le matin utilisé
aujourd'hui plus je décide de faire à
manger tout c'est des fois on se fait
des portes et on se fait tous à
spaghetti bon je peux pas faire ce pas
ce que ça va me coûter beaucoup plus
cher parce que si chère à prix bas ici
j'ai pas une bonne offre à un endroit je
vois la ja mais je dois voir ce que je
veux au final mais ici c'est pourquoi
mme sow avec les années christine a
développé ses stratégies pour économiser
du cosco
jean vanier où votre fils coûte 15 juin
québec après deux ans de taule à loin
fido d'un auteur c'est toute la compo ce
qu'on a fait avec les enfants céline ici
aussi les enfants de ces garderies à la
culture de légumes fait que vu qu'on
avait un comble les espaces avec les
tomates de redonner un peu de requêtes
sic accounts faire bnp dont le retour à
la terre fait partie de la solution
faut comprendre qu initialement les gens
trouvaient ça un peu fou devenir ferme
agriculture ici un même banc localement
les jantes est loin d'être convaincu ses
pions pompeux on peut comprendre
josée bélanger est une des fondatrices
du grenier boréale une coopérative
fondée en 2013
ici à longue pointe de mende à son pari
faire pousser fruits et légumes dans un
environnement peu propice à
l'agriculture
et voilà merci tout aussi s'y met avec
beaucoup d'efforts on est passé pas
c'est pas naturel comme on sue du québec
gérald qui pose bien ici le vraiment ce
les radis les navets échoue le suker on
a des tomates le décor
toutes les choses de chaleur on est
capable quand même d'enfants
on a cette préoccupation là nous de
favoriser l'accès en proximité on
s'assure d'être dans une moyenne de prix
le plus correct fouassier pour que les
gens puissent y accéder en fait le
grenier boréale est un bel exemple de la
prise en charge d'une communauté et
l'impact va au delà de l'agriculture
les jeunes redécouvrent en fait ce qu'il
faisait à petite échelle dans une
perspective plus de subsistance des
années antérieures cultivés localement
puis d'avoir accès à des produits à
l'issue de leurs efforts n'ont aussi
nous un rôle à jouer comme coopérative
le vandale le fait que bon la nutrition
c'est une question aussi qui permet
d'améliorer la santé etc
et l'éducation fait partie aussi du
mandat du grenier boréale nous
participer à l'instauration d'une serre
l'oci à l'école ici au village à longue
pointe de mingan ça permet aux enfants
en fait de découvrir que les légumes qui
viennent pendant savane rap le grenier
boréal a aussi donné un coup de pouce à
la création de cette serre à la co-op
les choix de marguerite à baie johan
beetz ce sont ses résidents qu'ils
devaient auparavant faire 120 kilomètres
pour acheter leur lait et qui se sont
regroupées pour mettre sur pied cette
coopérative en fait l'épicerie roule
depuis 2011
la solution c'était vraiment de partir
une coopérative qui donnait des services
de proximité
ça prend un investissement de tous les
habitants pour que ça fonctionne une
coiffe comme ça oui c'est sûr on a quand
même plus de 300 membres
puis on est juste c'est sa moins de 100
habitants donc il ya beaucoup de gens
qui pensent et qui trouve ça merveilleux
qui achètent leur carte de membre
le matin de notre passage les bénévoles
s'activent à regarnir le petit commerce
ces départements le plus compliqué parce
que les fruits et légumes avec le
transport c'est pas évident des fois il
y arrive un petit peu amoché d'où
l'importance de notre deuxième volet
c'est lassant donc ça nous permet du
moins pendant l'été d'avoir des produits
plus frais les gens se sont habitués à
aller à l'extérieur faire leurs
commissions faire leur épicerie
donc au début ça a été le défi de
ramener les gens à venir faire leur
épicerie ici c'est de faire comprendre
aux gens qu'ils ce n'est pas un
dépanneur c'est une épicerie conclu
c'est important que les gens qui vivent
avec johan beetz soit conscient de sa
pièce approvisionnent principalement
chez nous l'implication de julie et des
membres de la coopérative fait partie de
la solution aller sécurité alimentaire
mais malgré tous ses efforts le prix du
panier d'épicerie coûtera encore de 15 à
20% plus cher que dans les grands
centres et les situation n'est pas
unique à cette région
mes décisions politiques devront être
prises pour assurer la sécurité
alimentaire de tous les québécois
[Musique]